well as we just heard that study is
being carried out under the auspices of
the Alexander von Humboldt Foundation
which promotes academic cooperation
between scientists and scholars from
Germany and abroad to tell us more were
joined by its president time which farts
thank you very much for joining us here
at tomorrow today special to be here
Thank You grace and now your program is
aimed at giving German researchers
experience abroad as well as bringing
the talent back home can you tell us a
little bit about it and why it's so
important it is important because
science is being used as a kind of a
diplomacy of trust so we have around
26,000 scientists from all over the
world in 140 countries covering any area
and the interesting thing is that's a
home budget if from we have no quota we
do support people and the only cotillion
is you have to be excellent the research
project has to be superb and these two
criteria are what really matters to
become a humboldt fellow is there any
other tips you can give them if anyone's
listening in there well I think the most
interesting thing is you have to you
have to build for what you are doing
yeah if you are not really excited about
what you are doing the chances are low
but you have to be excellent there the
scale of what matters
as I mentioned nokotta nokotta for
gender no quota for age no quota for
conflicts that's it the old fashioned
enthusiasm and excellence amid
excellence yeah yeah and what about
perhaps a project that may have stuck
out in your mind in particulars or any
that it pops to your head well there are
two projects which I think this self to
be mentioned one is an art historian
from Princeton from Z instead of
Advanced Studies he is working on the
questions what secrets are hidden in the
genes of Salonga bards until is
combining art history with paleontology
this modern chemistry biology there is a
superb portrait and high school
elevating this scientists all over
Germany and the second one is from a
very different field the computer
scientists at Stanford University is
what it was a question is it conceivable
this Monday there will be so-called
autonomous car cars without drivers
using robots
yes well would you maybe maybe why not
most heavy traffic accidents are due to
the fact that humans make errors and he
believes that a computer is less
error-prone so these are two separate
projects but we have many more after all
the f-15 Nobel laureates among our
twenty among our twenty six thousand
room audience really innovative and
really exciting stuff I have to admit
and let's talk briefly about German
research what about the strengths what
are they well I think research is much
better than it's usually presented in
the media we have superb laboratories in
universities in the Max Planck as air
shaft that is Germany is extremely
attractive we get each year 2000
applications of the very best PhD
students from all over the world who
would like to spend up to two years in
Germany and then returned back to the
home country where they act as Germany's
best ambassadors Germany is I think a
kind of a paradise for researchers right
now it's a paradise for researchers and
it is attractive but what about the
language is that not difficult for
people too
it depends of course if if for example
somebody would like to work on the
philosophy of Heidegger it's awfully
helpful yeah if you have some tool and
of job but for natural scientists or so
I think the basic language is in most
laboratories John but by the way we do
offer any fellow the kind of a language
cause up to two months is that here T's
family can attend prior to starting the
work in Germany but that's not an offer
now I have not heard one before how rich
right thank you so much for joining us
here at smart oh thank you